crisis election grosser the lyrics may
be charged with the political message
but across Britain a generation of young
people feel left out election in
handsworth Birmingham they come to
workshops run by rapper Apache Indian
one of the local areas most famous son
he's used his own money to fund the
Academy for local young people will shut
down the youth clubs of sat down after
school clubs teachers don't have the
time lots of Kotzebue with funding they
see it as a way out of a deprived
community twenty-year-old Assad comes
here religiously he still hopes that
music rather than his day job will be
his future when it comes to politics he
has nothing positive to say no I don't
feel like a boring at all because it's
like or what they're doing to go to the
house apartment it is quite that is
talking a big bigger words his boss at
the factory is only 21 himself since
dropping out of college at sixteen to
work here he's risen to a senior
position 21 I've never voted I'll do
everything else what vote because I
don't feel like I know enough to give
accurate or an educated boat it's really
striking how many of the young people
I've spoken to hear feel completely
distant from politics even the most
basic level they're fully active members
of society with strong and deeply held
views it's as if they're only
disengagement is one specially reserved
for politics right now the Kenny report
man Gary Connery neighbor indication of
all free the reality of living in a
society without a voice hit Kenny a
method on when he was 16 imprisoned at a
young offenders institution for a crime
he did not commit he decided to change
his life was his reports are on key
issues like crime education and housing
they're compiled by a team of young
people and now they're influencing
politicians in Westminster he says young
people cannot afford to disengage
the cut stuff we've had to face in our
country we faced a brother we're the
ones who can't afford homes whether once
you have to pay the higher tuition fees
matters but Kenny says the onus is not
just on young people they must be
equipped to understand politics it's
very deliberate for me the fact that
we're not talk politics in school what
is an MP was a counselor how the hold
his people to account how do I get them
to do what I need to be done or how do I
organize people Mikey we need in order
that we can influence this photo she
will not talk that others are taking the
need to engage young people in the
political process a step further a
recent report argued that politicians do
not act in the interests of young people
because so few of them vote it suggests
first time voting should be compulsory
giving them a political voice that would
be impossible to ignore there's the
habitual element of voting so once you
vote in your first election you're far
more likely to continue to write which
is why we're recommending a compulsory
element to first time voting the young
people who say they feel hopeless
powerless and angry this is more than
just an election process it's a question
of how to turn those feelings into power
therefore hirsch Sky News